Let's shutter those windows, remove our blindfolds,
and take a good look at the film that caused
so much hype over the 2018 holiday season.
This is the untold truth of Bird Box.
Spoilers ahead!
While it may have felt like someone simply
took The Happening and A Quiet Place and smooshed
them together into a new film called Bird
Box, the director, Susanne Bier, has confirmed
that wasn't the case at all.
She told Polygon,
"No, no, no.
We were shooting [in April 2018] when we had
heard of A Quiet Place and we were almost
finished editing when it came out."
The film is actually based on the novel of
the same name, published by Josh Malerman
in 2014.
One major difference between the novel and
the film is the ending.
In the book, when Malorie, Boy, and Girl all
reach the sanctuary at the end of the river,
it doesn't turn out to be quite the paradise
they were expecting, considering the other
survivors have purposefully blinded themselves
for protection.
This change from a deflated, discouraging
end to a slightly more hopeful finale was
explained by director Bier, who pointed out,
"I'm not particularly interested for the audience
to leave, from the cinema or their own screen,
with a kind of completely bleak point of view."
One of the other larger deviations from the
original text came in the form of some significant
changes to a handful of the characters.
In the first act of the film, Malorie's sister
Jessica is quickly whisked away after she
sees a creature while driving Malorie home.
In the book, though, she survives along with
her sister for a few months before falling
victim to the monsters.
Malorie's love interest, Tom, was also altered.
Rather than surviving in the house and going
on to raise Boy and Girl with Malorie, he
falls victim to Gary while she is busy delivering
her baby.
And then there's Douglas.
While he ended up being a crucial part of
the movie, his character was entirely non-existent
in the book, although the novel's character
Dom seems to closely fit that role.
From Christian Bale's shocking transformation
for The Machinist to Colin Firth's preparation
for The King's Speech, the way an actor preps
for a role can be fascinating, and Bird Box
is no exception.
Bullock did some intense research before shooting
her blindfold scenes.
According to Mirror, Bier revealed that Bullock
spent time with a blind man who specializes
in teaching other blind people to navigate.
At one point, Bullock's commitment hurt her
on set, when her blindfold led her into a
collision with a camera that drew blood.
While she may have been committed to the role
regardless of her own safety, Bullock's passion
for authenticity did give way when it came
to the safety of others.
She had the blindfold reduced to a single
layer of thickness whenever she had to carry
her onscreen kids through a scene.
"There was always an element of me adhered
to those kids to make sure that I knew where
they were.
I needed to return them to their parents at
the end of the day, that was my goal."
Bullock trained to be able to move without
sight in Bird Box, but she purposefully didn't
prepare for another aspect of her character's
journey.
The first time she stepped into the boat that
takes her and the kids down the river, she
had no boating experience.
Bullock considered the story carefully and
decided to use her aquatic ignorance in her
favor, insisting that the river scenes be
filmed in chronological order so that her
rowing could look better as the movie progressed,
precisely as it would look for the equally
inexperienced Malorie.
At the end of Bird Box's first week, the Netflix
Twitter account posted a tweet boasting that
the movie had already been watched by an impressive
45 million accounts, giving it the "best first
7 days ever for a Netflix film!"
While that's a milestone worth celebrating,
many news outlets were quick to criticize
the figure as less meaningful than it seemed.
Netflix's tight control of its viewership
numbers has made any stat shared by the company
less trustworthy than the ratings system used
for cable and broadcast networks.
Did 45 million people really stream Bird Box
in its first week?
Maybe not, but the film's buzz certainly makes
it easy to believe that everyone and their
mother was watching this thing over the 2018
holiday break.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.